on
[Musique]
n'avait pas vu ça depuis longtemps
depuis plusieurs semaines les prix de
l'énergie explose le montant des
factures de gaz a augmenté de près de
50% depuis le début de l'année
ceux de l'électricité se diriger il y à
peu vers une hausse de 10 à 15% d'ici
février le sans plomb 95 a pris 25% sur
un an le gazole 30% mais en octobre le
gouvernement a sorti l'artillerie lourde
à coups de chèque énergie pour 5,8
millions de ménages de primes
anti-inflation 200 euros pour 30
millions de français et le gel des prix
du gaz d'abord durant l'hiver puis
finalement jusqu'à fin 2022 ne lésinant
pas sur les moyens financiers car le
coût total de ces mesures dépasse les 11
milliards d'euros et si l'exécutif en a
fait une de ses plus grosses
préoccupations de cette fin d'année ce
n'est pas sans raison car les prix de
l'énergie ou des carburants c'est un
sujet sensible
rappelez-vous 2018 et les gilets jaunes
le point de départ des manifestations
c'était justement le prix des carburants
et l'instauration d'une nouvelle taxe et
pour emmanuel macron lee gilet jaune
c'est un peu comme la casa des papes
elle mieux vaut s'arrêter à la saison 1
surtout si on veut se faire réélire
s'il a choisi pour le moment la
stratégie du carnet de chèques qui est
calme temporairement les esprits
peut-être jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle qui s'est pas sûr qu'elle
tienne éternellement car si les prix
continuent de monter au point de
franchir ce fameux bouclier tarifaire du
gouvernement il faudra envisager des
solutions sur le long terme une baisse
des taxes peut être sur le prix du gaz
un quart par dans les poches de l'état
sur les carburants c'est plus de la
moitié